الان الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
حيث اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اسقاط
مسيلتين اوكرانيتين في العاصمه موسكو
واوضحت الوزاره في بيان النكيه حاولت
تنفيذ مسمته عملا ارهابيا في موسكو عبر
استهداف عده منشات فيها واشارت الى ان
احباط هذه المحاوله تم بوسائل حرب
الكترونيه وان الحادثه لم يسفر عن وقوع
ضحايا من جانبه اعلن عمده موسكو
ان المستاجرات استهدفت مبنيين غير سكنيين
في العاصمه ان الهجوم لم يلحق اضرارا
بليغه بهما
وفي الاثناء قالت سلطات القرم المواليه
لروسيا انها اسقطت 10 مسيرات في شبه جزيره
القرم استهدفت مستودعا للذخيره كما قمت
السلطات باجلاء السكان من القرى المجاوره
لمكان الحادثه من جهاتها قالت وسائل اعلام
اوكرانيه ان انفجارات وقعت في منطقه
جانكوي بشبه جزيره القرم بعد استهداف
مستودعات اسلحه الى جيش الروسي في المنطقه
وذكرت ان الانفجارات ادت لتوقف حركه
القطارات في المنطقه وان السلطات المحليه
تعمل على اجلاء سكان ضمن دائره قطرها خمسه
كيلو مترات وفق الجانب الاوكراني